وليد العمري يعني هل هناك اي تناول لربما
ملف الاسرى مره اخرى واقدام اسرائيل على
هذه العمليات عمليه الاغتيال يوم امس الا
توجد خشيه ربما لتعرض الاسرى لاي
خطا الاسرى اذا كنت تقصد ابرام صفقه تبادل
للاسرى الان كافه المؤشرات ه المفوضات
بهذا الشان معلقه وبسبب عمليه الاغتيال تم
تاجيلها وتوقف نهائيا والمتهم هو من اغتال
العاروري ورفاقه في بيروت لانه كان من
الواضح اذا كانت اسرائيل فيها بعض
القراءات التي تقول ان اغتيال العاروري
سيضغط على السنوار وضيف من اجل ان يسرعا
في عمليه ابرام صفقه تبادل للاسرى هناك
قراءه اشد واقوى تقول بان الان الوضع قد
اختلف وليس بالضروره ان يرضخ زعيم حماس في
غزه السنوار وقائد المقاومه ضيف لهذه
التهديدات وهذا التصعيد من جانب اسرائيل
هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه اخرى ذوي الاسرى
انفسهم المحتجزين في قطاع غزه هم القلقون
الاوائل من ان مثل هذا الاغتيال سيعرض
ابنائهم المحتجزين في غزه للخطر خاصه وان
هناك اصرار على استمرار العمليه الحربيه
الاسرائيليه ولكن في مقابل ذلك هناك كتيار
اخر في الشارع الاسرائيلي يبدو ان كان
نتنياهو يحركه بالاساس وهو من سواء من
جنود قد سرحوا من المعركه في غزه او من
يمينيين متطرفين موالين له والذين يقولون
انه يجب المضي قدما في هذه الحرب دون
التوقف ايه ومواصلتها وهؤلاء نصبوا خيمه
اعتصام امام ديوان رئاسه الوزراء امس
مطالبين باستمرار الحرب وعدم توقفها كثقل
مضاد
لتحرك ذوي الاسرى المحتجزين في قطاع غزه
الذين يواصلون حراكهم في تل ابيب منذ
بدايه هذه الحرب هذا القلق يساور ذوي
الاسرى المحتجزين وكذلك يساور انصارهم
المؤيدين لهم لكن واضح انه في دائره صناعه
القرار في اسرائيل وتحديدا نتنياهو يبدو
ان ك ما يتهمونه لا يضع قضيه الاسرى
الاسرائيليين في
على في صداره سلم الاولويات وانما اصبحت
المعركه الاساسيه واستمرار القتال والحرب
هو الاساس